Usa los puntos (0, 0), (4, 5) y ("x", "y")
en la recta azul de la gráfica
para completar la ecuación, "y" entre "x" es igual a, nuestra incógnita...
Ésta es nuestra línea azul y aquí están
los puntos que nos mencionan (0, 0), (4, 5) y ("x", "y").
Nos piden escribir la ecuación de la recta
en la forma "y" igual a "mx".
"m" recordemos es la pendiente y la pendiente
se define como el cambio en "y" con respecto
al cambio en "x", entonces vamos a usar estos
elementos que nos dan, vamos a marcar cual
es la pendiente, vamos a tomar de estos puntos
que conocemos del (4, 5),
vamos a marcar aquí nuestro cambio en "y"... cambio...
esta delta de aquí, este triangulito,
es la letra griega delta y significa cambio,
entonces este es el cambio en "y".
Y aquí abajo vamos a poner, en otro color,
nuestro cambio en "x", del punto (0, 0)
hasta este otro punto, este es nuestro
cambio en "x", delta "x".
Y ahora podemos escribir nuestra pendiente
"m", esta "m" de acá...
"m" es igual a nuestro cambio en "y" entre
nuestro cambio en "x", delta "x".
Muy bien ¿cuál es este valor?
Bueno, si partimos de este punto a este punto,
el cambio en "y" es de 0 a 5,
así que nuestra delta "y" es de 5.
Esto es igual a 5 aquí arriba,
¿y cuál es el cambio en "x"?
Seguro ya lo vieron, partimos del origen de
este 0 y avanzamos 4 lugares hasta este punto,
0 a 4, la diferencia es de 4,
entonces nuestra delta "x" es 4.
Nuestra pendiente es de 5/4, pero nos están
pidiendo que la expresemos en esta forma.
Como sabemos, la pendiente en una recta va
a ser constante, nunca va a cambiar,
cualquier triángulo rectángulo...
éste recordemos que acabamos de hacer,
es un triángulo rectángulo, éste es un ángulo
recto, ya que este cambio en "y" es una línea
perfectamente vertical y el cambio en "x"
es una línea perfectamente horizontal,
se intersectan formando un ángulo recto y cualquier
triángulo rectángulo que formemos usando
cualquier par de puntos sobre esta recta,
va a tener esta proporción,
delta "y" entre delta "x" igual, van a ser constantes.
Así es que ahora es cuando usamos este punto
que nos dan ("x", "y"),
que es otro punto aleatorio de la recta.
Así que ahora, en otro color, voy a poner
cual es la diferencia en delta "y"
pero ahora de este punto de acá hacia mi eje "x",
más o menos por acá.
Este es mi cambio en "y" también pero ahora
tomando en cuenta este punto ("x", "y").
Mi cambio en "y" va a ser este punto "y",
aquí mi delta "y" es igual a este valor de
"y" que no estoy fijándome exactamente cual
es, es un punto aleatorio,
menos este otro valor en "y" que es 0, "y" menos 0.
Ahora, el cambio en "x" pues va a estar de
este punto de "x",
de este punto de ("x", "y") hacia el origen que es el que estoy tomando, este punto (0, 0).
Y ahora de éste, mi cambio en "x", delta
"x" es igual al valor "x" que tengo acá,
menos 0, que es el punto que estoy tomando
aquí, el origen, "x" menos 0.
Así que esta delta "y" entre delta "x", esta
nueva delta "y" que acabo de encontrar entre
delta "x"... delta "x"... éstas son iguales
a "y" menos 0 entre delta "x", "x" menos 0.
Muy bien, pero sabemos que la pendiente es
constante en toda esta recta.
Así que este valor es igual a este 5/4 de
acá, entonces esto va a ser igual a 5/4,
lo ponemos con los colores que corresponden
para que veamos de donde viene este valor.
Y pues para dejarlo en esta forma de "y" y
"x", pues vemos aquí que "y" menos 0 pues
va a ser "y" porque no le estamos restando
nada, igual aquí en "x", entonces podemos
dejarlo como "y" entre "x" es igual a 5/4
y para dejarlo de esta manera vamos a
multiplicar todo por "x".
Me va a quedar "y"es igual a 5/4 de "x" y
aquí está la ecuación que nos piden de esta manera.
Ahora vamos a ver la imagen de la
respuesta correcta.
Y aquí está la respuesta, la imagen es la
respuesta que pusimos, "y" igual a 5/4 de "x".
Y aquí está, correcto.
Así que nuestro análisis estuvo bien.
¡Nos vemos en el siguiente video!